[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est non loin de strasbourg à ostwald
petites communes d'alsace que nous
retrouvons isabelle morini bosc pour une
immersion dans l'univers du tatouage
c'est dans un salon dédié aux arts
corporels qu'elle débute son enquête et
cette nouvelle expérience risque de la
marquer au fer rouge
comment vous dire que ce n'est pas gagné
j'ai des tas de questions allant poser
parce que a priori le tatouage fait
vraiment vraiment vraiment mais vraiment
pas mon truc je comprends pas que les
gens s'esquinte ans en faisant mon
immersion débute au festival
international du tatouage d'oswald sur
plusieurs étages ce lieu propose de
multiples stands de tatouages des shows
burlesques du body painting de nombreux
magasins rock'n'roll de vêtements et de
piercing et autres bizarreries en tout
genre autrement dit j'ai tout à
apprendre et c'est fait ligne une
tatoueuse de la région qui m'accueille à
l'entrée
ah oui quand même s'est fait line
isabelle c'est des vrais
[Musique]
lundi place et donc dans aussi un petit
peu un zèle en salle et deux chats qui
rien là bas qu elle alors berk berk à
tête de maure berbère j't'explique on
m'a confié la mission d'autres l'ont
fait parce qu'avant de pouvoir aller
voir un bouquet ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire tu vois mon look
oui mais tout à l'heure tu vas amoureux
semblaient un petit peu alors ça c'est
pas désobligeants du tout de ma part
mais ça ne ment pas rassure toi mais non
mais non on saluera sur ses ailes et on
y va
je suis là paraît qu'un relooking
s'impose et je crains le pire
féline me présente vanessa responsable
d'une boutique du salon ont pour le
moins rock'n'roll
si vous voulez jeter un petit coup
d'oeil pour se plonger dans le thème
barock'n roll indirectement des choses
comme ceci peut-être cccg quoi si les
têtes de mort donc les oui oui tu étais
tellement 8 des petites têtes de membres
mais non merci
c'est un petit peu le thème ici ça va
être compliqué un tout tout tout vous
n'y a que des têtes de mort c'est pas
que ça démarre mal mais non là on a des
petits poneys va prendre la tête de mort
visiblement pour les filles la tenue ça
ne suffit pas elles ont l'air très
inspiré et on pensait la norme est
vraiment à tous comment vous dire à mon
grand désespoir
sinon j'ai des pièces et a plutôt envie
septembre et octobre après pas mal ça un
petit septembre c'est quoi cet homme je
n'avais jamais battu le toubib ça tout
de suite mais non il n'y a pas de trou
tu vas voir ta femme et moi j'ai pas
signé pour faire sucer signés pour
enquêter sur vous comment dire c'est
comme l'impression de m'être fait avoir
mais j'accepte malgré tout de rentrer
dans les clous pour me mettre dans la
peau d'une hta toulouse
mais c'est super c'est génial voilà un
petit malin qui fait un commentaire
j'arrête tout je m'en vais allez vas-y
le bandana ça et puis j'oublie pas de
septembre ces classes ne bougeait pas et
c'est dégueulasse
[Musique]
c'est pas mal c'est parfait ouais non
c'est dégueulasse et tout
arrive le pire pour la suite de
relooking on me confie ce 2 mai collier
autant dire c'est comme si on m'enlevait
un organe mais une fois de plus je
capitule non mais ça fait vieille [ __ ]
mais vraiment non mais attends mais
c'est pas possible ça mais c'est simple
dans la tête demandent pardon remercie
mon compte j'ai beaucoup de mal à
assumer ce loupé un surmoi
l'accoutrement paraît grotesque cash
mois le plus possible commentaire
le pire est à venir céline me conduit à
son stand et elle veut que j'aille
encore plus loin dans le relooking à 8
424 il faut que ça ait jamais joué
la vie mais j'ai envie de te faire
plaisir à mon épouse et moi regarde ce
que je fais
les tatouages temporaires
fierté de l'éphémère ça dure entre trois
et cinq jours et par contre je
reviendrai donc de tatouages
je le fais vraiment d'etel demain tu
râles pas c'est parce que je t'aime bien
au moins j'apprends des choses le
tatouage temporaire c'est un art
corporel né aux etats-unis alors à
l'aide d'un pochoir l'encré projetée sur
la peau pour reproduire le dessin est
comme son nom l'indiqué bien c'est
éphémère la tête devant jean labellie ce
matin jouer en bleu après midi je
préfère une merde noire
ma comprise oui j'ai compris un peu que
tu peux pas
garde les mâles totalement
tu mets dans la rue
alors je dois l'avouer c'est bluffant
cette technique de tatouages éphémères
et l'illusion est absolument parfaite
alors où la vache mais j'ai l'impression
d'avoir encore moins de cinq d'habitude
pourtant cessé de bomber le torse à sept
sages ont soufflé dedans ou le choc du
choc thermique 1 couture honnêtement
j'en reste sans voix je me sens
exactement dans la peau du mec qui c'est
un tatouage dans les années 60 sur une
harley davidson et qui donc maintenant
commencent à fléchir de plats tire de
partout et les tatouages aussi c'est
sans appel je ne me reconnais pas pourvu
que ça ne colle pas à la peau tout au
long de l'immersion quelques petites
retouches
le tatouage éphémère est terminée et
forcément à part moi ça ne choque
personne
[Musique]
mais la vie mais je reconnais que celui
de madame il est magnifique création la
cuisse on voit pas pour saab le mois
dernier c'est une singly
bravo les claques m'appartient à moi je
pense que chaque date moi je refais la
personnalité de quelqu'un et aussi sûrs
en discutant avec ces passionnés je
saisis mieux l'intérêt pour le tatouage
je prends conscience que derrière chaque
dessin réside un aspect esthétique qui
cache souvent une dimension très
symbolique au contact des visiteurs du
salon
je vais en apprendre davantage il ya
tellement de choses à voir sur vous
honnêtement je ne sais pas par quoi
commencer ce qui est sûr c'est que si on
s'embête au lit avec vous il ya de quoi
faire en lecture sur mer du japon mais
c'est des tribus qui vous était
découragé beaucoup d'émules sûrement
pourquoi parce que c'est une fusion
fiscaux comme un journal intime un peu
sur la pauvre sa part jamais quoi ça qui
plus est il sincère qu est la vie
d'avant
un tatouage politique
inventons du tatouage pour les fixer au
x trem grand soin extrême droite plus
cotés et mêlant ça doit vous gêné de le
montrer dans certains cas suspects y est
lent mais même si ça me vante pas mal de
questions
on en sait quelque chose mais hier elle
fait partie de ma vie mais je
ma vie parce que c'est ce qui m'a
construit c'est ce qui fait que
maintenant je suis ce que je suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis tellement sidéré par cet échange
que j'ai d'autant plus envie d'aller
plus loin dans mon enquête
avec bientôt un nouveau sujet d'étude
mais pour ce faire nous deux
constat vous avez la focale ouvert dès
vos lunettes 30 secondes je passe sur
l'autre c'est bien creux matinée pour
bien son tatouage était tout noir que
vous avez assez des tatouages
combien de centaines de milliers d'euros
l'an bâtir babineau j'ai commencé la
saison j'ai 30 ans
en presque quinze ans de savoir avant
réponse est venue l'idée du visage
j'appelle ça c'est comme des tatouages
des tatouages mais nous avons vite
toujours plus
donc le niveau suprême à sept visages
hélas moi c'est les choses les plus
importantes de l'année
attendez je vais le voir un truc
incroyable ouvrez la bouche
[Musique]
jamais lors du coup on a un bon sens
vous avez une bouche une langue bien
dépendantes
et une croisade
et hop l'homme est complet on peut se
dire que si je me couper la langue ça
spécialiste fait que des modifications
des scarifications les apports sous la
peau et la langue car les oreilles
d'elfe tout est possible en fait il ya
personne qui vous dit pourquoi vous
faites pas de décès en de psychothérapie
il ya des personnes santos tard cravate
pas de problème car les coupes des
choses moi avait il forme alors
peut être ai je dit c'est ça l'espagne
est encore très joli mais très joli je
découvre un monde dont j'ignorais
complètement les codes cette enquête je
dois dire me réserve de vraies surprises
et je me demande ce que va être la suite
[Musique]
isabelle morini-bosc prend ses marques
dans l'univers du tatouage
elles vont années l'apprentissage des
techniques de cet art corporel et pour
s'exercer tous les supports feront la
faire
elle va suivre une formation express
mais ce qu'elle ignore c'est qu'elle va
devoir réaliser son premier véritable
tatouage sur un modèle en chair et en os
[Musique]
puis se terminera son enquête dans une
clinique parisienne où elle découvrira
les dernières technologies de détatouage
isabelle s'apprête à vivre une immersion
qui risque de la rendre à fleur de peau